we want to play a little game with you
guys it is called get to know to around
ten best treat yourself meal after a
long rehearsal affable
healthy most likely to get emotional
during rehearsal so many times like
tears so frustrated when I don't get
sleep yeah and like I get frustrated
that he's like trying to be patient and
yet it's taking like an hour to get
three steps and it's just like I feel so
bad how do you talk her down when that's
happening yeah okay no you know it's
it's it's it's like the heat of the
moment you know it's so frustrating in
the moment and then once you get it it's
like it's yeah and so honestly I learned
that with her the more we just keep
doing it and then she finally gets it
that's when she like let loose another
like okay I got it now we can do it
again she's taught you anything
patience she's super light hearted
Alexis tries to have a lot of fun and
rehearsals and sometimes you can see her
like trying to make me laugh and I'm
like do it again my scene have you heard
it it's pretty good country girl
my audition for American Idol I'm really
good at puzzles is that weird that's
awesome when you're gonna be old in the
nursing home that's gonna be awesome
the movie that you could watch over and
over and over again inside up that's a
good movie there's so many movies though
I don't know I just I don't I change I
like a lot yeah I don't have like a
movie that I sit down and watch like
seven times
weirdest quirk you might answer for each
other Alexis let's see
she does she always thinks I process
though her lips
what's his you gotta get him back now
his entire personality is a quark idea
of a perfect date Netflix and I don't
know it depends on the mood sometimes
I'd like to go to a nice restaurant
sometimes a movie I'm adventurous I like
a lot of things what do you guys do
outside of Dancing with the Stars
rehearsals yeah one thing that you'll
never post on Instagram hmm I don't know
I try not to post my family because I
like want to keep their privacy I don't
know I feel like I post most things that
aren't so personal I mean I'll post my
family just do I love my family and I
just you know but we have nothing to
hide and last one your dream song to
dance to right now I really like hurt
from Johnny Cash I love doing more like
emotional dances like contemporary and
stuff so I've been really wanting to
dance to feel angry G by Will Smith
[Music]